dans un écosystème naturel dans une
forêt par exemple les feuilles vont
tomber au sol et fertiliser la terre
chaque année dans un champ cultivé on
récolte les plans donc on retire des
nutriments et pour fertiliser la terre
on ajoute des engrais chimiques ou
organiques mais cette façon de faire
peut épuiser le sol voilà pourquoi
certains misent désormais sur des
produits moins connus que les engrais
les bio stimulant
[Musique]
c'est denis petit village france
ascquois à quelques kilomètres de
saskatoon
cette communauté vit de l'agriculture
depuis des générations les fermes
familiales s'étendent à l'infini dans
toutes les directions
michel lepage cultive ici des grès et
des légumineuses sur 425 ha du terrain
vallonné ils constatent depuis longtemps
que ces rendements sont moins bons sur
le haut des buts en raison de l'érosion
du sol les pratiques agricoles de son
père et de son grand-père en serait la
cause et se servait de la bande haute et
du hrc pts est la pire chose que tu peux
faire pour qu'elle seule soit dans une
grande chose qui va pas partir au vin la
préservation de ces terres est devenu
une priorité aujourd'hui on croit
beaucoup dans la qualité le maintien du
seul pour les futures générations
[Musique]
au prête en 2021 il décide d'ajouter un
nouvel entrant à ces semences de
lentilles et de moutarde un bios
stimulant sous forme de pastilles qui a
pour but d'augmenter la vie microbienne
et fongiques dans le sol ils souhaitent
ainsi augmenter si rendements à long
terme on se faire d un fertilisant
partie celle industriels qui font neuf
des éléments importants pour la
production de nos récoltes mais
c'est plus compliqué que ça
michel lepage est l'un des premiers
agriculteurs à utiliser ce bio stimulant
à grande échelle
ce nouveau produit a été développé dans
le petit village francophone de zénon
park sur la ferme de clément perreault
depuis une vingtaine d'années le
producteur s'inquiétaient de la santé de
six chants des terres qu'il a lui même
aidé à défricher
jeu du bois que de l'eau au cul des lacs
puis qu'ils n'y ont commencé à défricher
puis je renonçais des racines dont le
bas apple envoya là car étape est à
vraiment belle est un homme en pleine de
vie otis un minot alors que c'est des
bonnes récoltes
[Musique]
mais dans les années 60 l'avènement de
l'agriculture intensive vient changer la
donne car gens commencent à me des
engrais et ont commencé tranquillement y
avait du bon rendement ça marche à bain
puis donne a commencé à n'utiliser plus
parce qu'on pensait qu'on pourrait avoir
des meilleurs rendements mais là c'est
rendu hier met beaucoup plus qui pour
juste maintenir laurent demain qui est
mon père héros décide alors dépendre du
fumier composté sur ses pâturages de
bovins biologique
le résultat l'interpellent je
m'intéresse à dessus peut on arrive
lorsque la lame devenu vert va rester
vert tout l'été il se demande alors
comment transposer les bénéfices du
fumier composté à la production de
grandes cultures sur des centaines
d'hectares
si recherches le mènent en france en
2010 où il découvre les pieds ou
stimulant des produits biologiques qui
stimulent chez la plante l'absorption
des nutriments et qui nourrissent les
sommes ou la poche sinon clément
perreault fonde par la suite un
partenariat avec conrad du hem à
grenoble belge qui s'intéressent au
développement des biotechnologies
agricoles
malgré tous les progrès qu'on amenait en
termes de pesticides en termes de gammes
génétique il y avait une espèce de
plateau qui s'installait dans l'est dans
les productions agricoles on savait
aussi d'autre part que les chambres
d'agriculture conventionnelle eux ne
stocke et absolument plus de de carbone
stocker du carbone c'est vraiment faire
en sorte que ce qu'ils mettent ce qu'ils
apportent comme engrais ou n'importe
quel type d'entre eux restent dans leurs
champs ils ne savent ceva portable
les grandes cultures n'absorbant moyenne
que 60% des engrais chimiques et pendu
dans les champs la raison principale un
manque de matière organique dans le sol
qui aide les cultures absorber les
nutriments
1940 1950 qu'il fallait de calories
d'énergies fossiles pour produire de
calories alimentaires maintenant il en
faut 10 pour produire une calorie
alimentaire donc il faut rendre à
l'agriculture son efficience
[Musique]
si le labour des terres a presque cessé
depuis vingt ans les sols des prairies
sont tout de même visiblement dégradées
après des décennies d'agriculture
intensive
la terre végétale c'est à dire le sol
arable que l'on trouve sur une vingtaine
de centimètres à la surface deschamps a
disparu par endroits un constat
inquiétant puisque c'est dans cette
couche de terre que se trouve la plus
importante concentration de micro
organismes
[Musique]
dans ses champs au nord ouest d'origine
à une équipe de chercheurs mesure la
quantité de matière organique à la
surface
jeff chaînon un directeur d'une chaire
de recherche à l'université de la
saskatchewan sur la gestion de
nutriments dans le sol
son équipe prélève des échantillons de
terre jusqu'à une profondeur de 60 cm
cette couleur blanchâtre ce sont des
carbonates de calcium
ils sont visibles en surface car
l'érosion a balayé la terre arable ce
type de sol en ph plus élevés et compte
y ait moins de matière organique bref
y'a pas grand chose qui va pousser ici
les chercheurs mesurent l'impact de
différentes approches pour augmenter la
productivité de ses sols dégradés il
conclut que l'une des meilleures
solutions c'est d'y ajouter de la
matière organique composter
ce qui est essentiel au bon
fonctionnement des sols c'est la matière
organique c'est-à-dire l'humus en se
décomposant il agit comme un substrat en
nourrissant les micro-organismes qui
nourrissent à leur tour les plantes ce
cycle est capital pour assurer la
viabilité des sols à long terme
cette partie là qui manquait dans le sol
et c'est ce que qu'on essaie de
reconstituer cet équilibre de flore
qu'il nous faut
mais où trouver suffisamment de matières
organiques ont postés pour alimenter les
superficies immense des prairies
l'entreprise eu matière à se tourner
vers les municipalités à saskatoon vingt
mille tonnes de déchets organiques sont
recueillis chaque année surtout des
déchets de jardinage et des résidus
alimentaires
le compost produite ici sert au projet
d'embellissement de la ville et est
offert à ses résidents
printemps 2021 un camion semi-remorque
vient récupérer 25 tonnes de compost
destiné aux chants des prairies
[Musique]
trois heures plus tard on le retrouve à
la ferme de clément perreault hazen en
parc
le compost est d'abord tamisée avant de
passer à l'étape de la biochimie
on y ajoute alors des nutriments et des
minéraux qui favoriseront la croissance
de bactéries et de champignons et c'est
simple le changement de paradigme c'est
que le composent devient une façon de
produire un ensemble équilibré de
bactéries et de champignons
[Musique]
le mélange de compost et de nutriments
est transformé en pastilles le produit
fini qui sera vendue aux fermiers on
essaie de reproduire des écosystèmes qui
existait dans la paille et qui existait
dans le dans le sol de la forêt donc ce
qu'on fait c'est c'est importer des
nutriments supplémentaire pour que ces
bonnes bactéries et cette bonne
microbiologiques puisse se développer
une fois de retour dans le sol
les bio stimulant représente tout de
même une dépense important pour les
fermiers michel lepage à payer 4000 $ en
2021 pour en répandre dans ses champs de
lentilles et de moutarde soit 50 dollars
par hectare une dépense qu'il devra
prévoir chaque année si on est pour
investir d'argent pour améliorer le
solde noonan à l'autre il faut voir un
retour sur investissement l'entreprise
eut mattera soutient que son bios
stimulant permet d'augmenter les
rendements de 10 à 40% à long terme cela
se ferait entre autres par une
utilisation beaucoup plus efficace des
engrais chimiques se destine à les
utiliser mieux à diminuer les pertes par
lessivage à diminuer la perte par
évaporation aussi reconstitué en même
temps le sol
et insolence santé souligne jeff
chesneau devrait mener à une réduction
des intrants chimiques à long terme
comme la matière organique favorise la
rétention des nutriments et l'améliorent
sans doute l'efficacité et le
rétablissement des sols et en bout de
ligne ça veut dire qu'on rentabilise
l'argent dépensé pour l'achat d'engrais
[Musique]
une mattera aventure en 2007 et 1 5
mille tonnes de bio stimulant qui ont
été épandus sur plus de cent mille
hectares en saskatchewan
une nouvelle usine est en chantier qui
aura une capacité de production
dix fois plus grande
l'entreprise mise sur une prise de
conscience de plus en plus grande chez
les agriculteurs quant à l'importance de
la santé des sols pour
sabri 40 à le détruire ça va prendre un
cours d'année m
michel lepage de son côté n'aura pas pu
évaluer l'impact des bio stimulant sur
ses champs en 2021 une sécheresse en
saskatchewan a réduit de moitié les
rendements dans ses champs de lentilles
et de moutarde qu'importe sa décision
est prise il ajoutera de nouveaux débits
aux stimulants asséchant en 2022 l'enjeu
est trop important à la nature autant
qu'on l'a but puis on pense que l es
capable de revenir et
reprendre des forces c'est un phénomène
fragile qu'on devrait conserver pour le
bienfait de nos générations à venir